what's up guys i'm dave klein aka dave
control and i was lucky enough to get my
hands on a few hours of elden ring as
part of its network test while a lot of
my time was spent discovering dungeons
exploring those and defeating bosses
that doesn't mean there weren't a number
of cool secrets i discovered along the
way
in fact that's something i've always
loved about from software games there
are things you don't have to find but
help flesh out the game and its lore
so here are 5 secrets from the alden
ring network test
within the region of limb grave there's
a beach players were able to access on
this beach were these cool corrupted
turtle cross octopus enemies whose weak
spot was their head
an npc merchant who very specifically
didn't want any trouble what do you need
i don't want any trouble
and something invisible running along
the beach leaving these spirit tracks so
of course the thing to do is attack it
and as it turns out you can kill this
enemy who ends up dropping an ash of war
determination
ashes of war are new to eldon ring and
act as equippable weapon skills these
can also change the stats of your weapon
interestingly after killing the enemy it
appears to be one of the many dung
beetle types who you can find roaming
the open world of eldon ring depending
on the color of the i guess dung these
creatures roll you'll receive a
different reward for killing them this
could be hp flask refills fp flask
refills or even ashes of war
it's time to talk about dragon heart
how will you make a living night shut up
no this one
in the elden ring network test one of
the many bosses players were able to
fight was the flying dragon agile upon
killing this dragon you'll receive a
dragon heart the description reads
dragon heart seized by a dragon tracker
it has a bizarre shape modeled by gravel
and it continues to beat vivaciously an
offering used in the dragon communion
consume a dragon's heart at the altar to
make its power yours while a terrible
and savage looking thing the heart has a
peculiar beauty to it and you can also
talk to bloody finger hunter yura who
will let you know
the heart you brought back
it's used in dragon communion if you
should find yourself overcome by hunger
for the heart
yearning for its strength
then seek the decrepit church
on the little island of the western
coast
so after defeating a demi-human chief
boss you can make your way over to the
church of dragon communion here if you
have the dragon heart you can perform
dragon communion which by doing so will
let you receive grail's roar an
incantation of the dragon communion used
by those who've eaten of a dragon heart
manifest the power of the great ancient
dragon rail to sound a fearsome roar the
roar of the great grail foreboding as a
mountain overcomes all who hear it with
its might their attack power is
temporarily decreased
i can't wait to see what else you can
get through the dragon communion
you must not forget though
those who partake in dragon communion
will one day shed their humanity
their hunger for dragon
their yearning
only worsens
until the floodgates burst
unleashing eternal torment
the strength of a mighty dragon
magnificent
but deadly it's no surprise that dragon
communion
is ruinous
on the eastern side of elder ring storm
hill is a statue with something glowing
inside in order to get to his inner
goodies players will need to aggro one
of the nearby giants and allow the giant
to break the statue for you in the
network test inside of the statue were
six smithing stone shards
nice
the last secret i found and one i
personally didn't get to see through to
the end
near agile lake north there's a hidden
npc bach will call out to you boy
you you there
could you help us out kelly
if you have trouble finding bach call
lament you
yeah you there
stop pretending you can't see me
why won't anyone look me in the eye
i'm i'm not that ugly am i
as it turns out by swinging at a nearby
tree you'll be able to break the spell
bach was kicked out of a cave on the
shore had his possessions stolen and was
transformed into a tree he rewards you
with the glowstone for helping him out
and offers to risk returning to his cave
to find his possessions and give you a
greater reward i traveled to the
dissenters cave which was the only cave
on a shore available in the network test
to see if bach would show up there
but he never showed up i also checked
back at his original location and he had
left i did do some research to see if
anyone else had found out where this
quest line goes but so far it seems like
this might be something that's continued
outside of the limitations of the
network test
for those of you who have watched elton
ring footage pre-release pumpkin head is
probably pretty well known thanks to his
fun design and the awesome helmet you
get for defeating him now that's elden
bling
but he's actually a bit of a secret to
find on the eastern edge of limb grave
on the border of what was playable
within the network test are posttown
remains
these remains hold a giant poisonous
flower that you can duke it out with as
well as a dungeon that can only be
accessed by double jumping over a small
section of walls with your steed
it's in this hidden dungeon that
pumpkinhead can be found along with the
sorceress selen who sells
well sorceries i dare say your
proclivities are far from ideal
oh well perhaps nurture will define
nature
with a bit of luck
but one must choose one's masters wisely
i was exiled from the academy of real
lucaria
as a reviled apostate witch
do you still wish to learn from me
while pumpkin head isn't the most
difficult fight it's still always fun to
go up against a slower but powerful foe
um
so there you have the most interesting
secrets from the network test i was able
to find while i realized the network
test is now closed these will likely
still be secrets that behave the same in
the final game and i do think it's
exciting to see that from software is
still at it keeping in content you don't
necessarily need to find
if you played the network test were
there any secrets i missed mentioning or
do you possibly know about the end of
the block quest line let me know thanks
so much for watching and if you'd be
interested in watching a full network
test let's play from me and seeing my
experiences that's also up on gamespot
and i'll see you guys next time
[Music]
you